o lado pessoal de que fala a dar que
sejam muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo e
hoje trago de que estou a quem contrata
mão gosto aqui com uma pistola quente e
eu tenho aqui alguns materiais um deus é
não quis ter uma mão em borracha acho
que eu não faço nenhuma tal bank dentro
tem aqui também uma cobra gigante uma
usa isto mas eu acho que é bala neva de
coca cola gigantes mas isto pesa um
quilo um funk luís tem muita caloria
aqui o big one um quilo sai muito grande
esta corre cheira mesmo carregou eu
prometi que ia explodir coisas assim
mais perigosos não é portanto eu tenho
aqui uma bateria de nokia é a bateria
que os mandei do nóqui 3310 eu queria
dizer que faz explodir mas agora vou ter
muito mais cuidado e não queimar a pele
porque eacute em vídeo eu sei mas já só
tá muito bem as coisas
vamos tentar cozinhar uma batata eu só
tenho 11 réus nessa eu consegui isso vai
dar certo já que cortar algumas puderam
usar mais
agora sim bairro
eu adoro esse barulho além 400 graus 500
graus tasso 'beta' subducção tasso 600
o jato sentir o cheiro a tabaco
ok vamos virar lei o conef brasil só
terá sido a equipe já precisa vir agora
[Aplausos]
halep por aí além
então eu acho que a cabeça fica pra mim
cabo brilharam em pó que é hora de virar
[Aplausos]
tropas e bolhas no entanto se cuida
eu acho que a áfrica
eu acho que ele usa
aí acho que é esperado no 132 ou
produção está horrível
op o que podem vir a estatal vai mais
fina portanto vou tentar esta época
pedro golf e instrutores turismo que sai
pedaço do lábio
só que da nossa batata escolar não está
muito mal e não façam isso em casa
pessoal ficou visível este mês ao
escalar até ficar bom mas eu não me
esqueço batatas que isso vai estar
próximo o objeto mas será que a nossa
mão eu quero muito saber o que tem aqui
dentro mas você esteja aqui proteção
portanto se pegar fogo eu tenho que ver
né eu tenho aqui algo que vai pegar fogo
muito bem a água evapora colocar eu vou
estar aqui passa para 3 2
e eu ficava no youtube ou o que se
passou ea cheirar a a plástico queimado
ea fab
[Aplausos]
o tom que meu beijo não sou burra que um
cabrio que o hotel em lei e até o dalton
está a já sei que isto é isso que é de
plástico só que em fibras mais pequenas
e então não perdoa o taxista adão mesmo
fui
olha só vejam só que eu pudesse só
existe porque é tudo muito rápido a lei
rio vejam só como ficou nas mãos do teu
eu vou tentar agora é só quebrar o dedo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
à já percebi é por isso que eu disse que
tinha posso aqui só recentemente
inaugurado mas também tem um espírito de
45 nep mas é isso já descobrimos o que
tem dentro da mão eu vou tentar agora só
quer barulho rock no hospital
e oh
o paulo ainda a equipe toque de sorte
que sua mão esquerda não quer só vão
continuar assim tomar vamos agora então
tentar queimar aqui nossa mega super
coca cola de um quilo eu vou comer
estudar o uso de um gostoso ou o agora
independente machin chegou a língua
também está a nove
vejam só fala aí
[Aplausos]
isso não é só gigante é muito gigante já
a vontade de comer estudo
[Aplausos]
isso é o sonho de qualquer golo e juro e
chora muito
ae achei que o dinheiro chega agora sim
está chegando aí a da xuxa gostoso sair
e tentanto superpopular nessa coisa que
acho que confiam em baixo na zona
vamos fazer por onde estão ainda a
expulsão aqui do hotel e nós temos uma
bomba
eu tenho que fazer isso antes de
tomarmos aqui na nossa cola eu vou ter
que provar qualquer 32 e aí é muito duro
golpe estava quente contra a coca cola
de um quilo
eu vou tentar abrir um buraco no meio da
qual e vamos ver o que acontece com o
twitter
um lado acho justo o que aconteceu sol
eu vou tentar correr assim num um sabor
melhor assim né meu cérebro fica muito
bom assim
já a ficar escuro essa paisagem é linda
linda olha essa mas a bola chega agora é
um importante é o vídeo agora que tá
continuam a subir e os discurso fica
branco e meu agente muito perto explica
que pontas de uma a próxima que fica
muito perto lei
brundle de não estão a conseguir ouvir o
barulho de uma tinta trincar mas está
bom o terrorismo
[Música]
esse debate está tudo encaminhando
cultura
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o caíque eu vou estar aqui quando eu
olhei e olha que só olha só essa camada
desconfiado fica muito gostoso lê é
quase impossível furar aqui coca cola
porque ela é bem grossa da prisa faca o
que eu vou tentar separar a lei é muito
forte também olha aí não dá para separar
[Música]
só siga coca cola e vamos lá então ao
mais perigoso da nossa bateria de nokia
meu está muito errado
a cápsula com a equipa teria e agora
vamos tentar aquecer
só não tem isso em casa caiu assumir o
risco é que tá não faço nada em casa à
noite e méxico vão puxar água
[Aplausos]
eu acho que pedro vá curtir
[Música]
[Aplausos]
não acontece nada só para o poste ateu é
que já só tem metal
eu vou tentar agora que ser um tal ii
[Aplausos]
pessoalmente não sou assim também eu
acho que a bateria só percebeu o fogo
ela podendo agora então é isso ao buscar
porque os filhos para passear tenham
gostado apesar da bateria não ter
rebentado eu acho que ficou engraçado já
sabem quanto o vosso bike comentário e
aí não se esqueçam aqui no vasco a vocês
vão ter dois filhos provavelmente não
viram e aqui em cima vocês podem se
inscrever é que mostramos a eif quem vai
até a próxima